[Music]
with kian reeves and his character john
wick a favorite killer will surely be
returning to the big screen
last monday shooting began in berlin for
what is now the fourth part of the
series although the official synopsis is
not yet known
we can expect a fierce revenge campaign
of jon and the bowery king
against the high table correspondingly
the cast is also growing
so besides keanu reeves there will be
lawrence fishburne rina samoyama
and shamir andersen as well as donnie
yen and hiroyuki sanada
the latter not only acts on the actors
but also true
legends in the field of martial arts
this will be quite convenient for the
characters they portray
as we expect him to fight against john
wick rather than with him
so we can look forward to even more
elaborate fight scenes and await the
release of john wick chapter 4 on may 27
2022 after we recently learned that the
upcoming aquaman sequel will be called
aquaman of the lost kingdom director
james wan posted another hint about the
film's plot on social media
as we previously reported judging by the
title aquaman 2 will most
likely revolve around the missing 7th
kingdom in connection with one's post
from the set which
also marks the shooting star of the dc
sequel and the nicuras scene on the clap
aboard
this story is now slowly but surely
taking more concrete shape
nekros is certainly a reference to the
atlantic city of the same name which
emerges from the seas only irregularly
and
never in the same place the city also
has a malevolent ruler named [ __ ] for
whom we can
perfectly imagine game of thrones
villain pillow aspect who signed on in
april
in any case we are happy that filming
has now started and we are eagerly
awaiting the release on december 16
2022 as we reported last week the
responsible parties announced the
official title of the seventh
transformers movie namely
rise of the beasts this is followed
directly by another announcement
we can look forward to the signing of
ron perlman who won the golden globe for
his role in the tv series beauty and the
beast among others
the 71 year old actor with a striking
appearance will voice the character
optimus primal and this is not the first
time as pearlman was already responsible
for the dubbing of the maximal's leader
in the transformers franchise prime wars
trilogy in terms of content transformers
rise of the beasts is set in the 1990s
after the events of bumblebee
you will not only see the old familiar
decepticons in front of the camera but
above all
also the maximals who are capable of
transforming into mammals as well as
the predacons who are at least partial
descendants of the decepticons
last but not least the terracons who
some kind of re-animated machine
creatures
are a new addition we are excited about
further information on the upcoming
transformers rise of the beasts
and are looking forward to the expected
release date on june 24th
2022 after part 11
it's over this is just about everything
you need to know about the main series
of the fast and furious
franchise it has been known for some
time that the series will likely go into
outer space in the meantime
and it is also no secret that many would
like to see crossover with the jurassic
world franchise which is also set to end
soon
now fast and furious star tyres gibson
is taking things of another notch and is
hoping for a crossover with transformers
frankly this idea is only half as absurd
as vin diesel's who is probably about to
retire having a velociraptor stuck to
his grill in a 1970 dodge charger while
fleeing from two t-rex
so it does make sense that huge machines
meet fast sports cars while the action
aspect which has been emphasized since
fast and furious 5 at the latest
should not be lacking either with
decepticons and the likes
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
after all these are by
no means official plans so far they are
merely tyrus gibson's fantasies
even though this idea has been met with
a lot of positive feedback from the
community the ninth
fast and furious movie has been playing
in theaters since june 25th
what at first sounded like a weird rumor
might have actually been confirmed now
because
marvel is said to have changed one of
the two post-credit scenes of the disney
play series one division in the
aftermath
more specifically it concerns episode 9
in which wanda stays in a lonely forest
cabin to study the darkhold
at first glance some cosmetic change is
unnoticeable that is that the trees look
a bit paler and also that the light is
slightly altered
however what is now causing quite a stir
is a difficult to recognize outline in
the forest sliding down the hill
apparently this figure is meant to be dr
strange after all wanda is expected to
play a crucial role in the upcoming
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
but is that really the case we don't
believe so and reddit uses xenophobe
provides the most
plausible reason in a simple video it
seems that the light shining out of the
window of the cabin has been edited out
the problem is that they forgot to
remove the effect from the rest of the
scene as well
which is why it looks like a mysterious
figure is flying down the mountain
in other words it's a hoax still there
are two possibilities why the scene was
changed optically either it also appears
on doctor strange on the multiverse of
madness and was adjusted to avoid
continuity errors
or we're really just talking about a
clumsy mistake by the creators which can
be traced back to the stressful schedule
during the pandemic
nevertheless the whole thing generated
quite a bit of buzz although it was
debunked in the end
quentin tarantino is a man in great
demand who always seems to have work to
do
he is currently promoting his book once
upon a time in hollywood and chats about
other projects
along the way the joe rogan podcast also
discussed a possible kill bill 3 and it
looks like tarantino has a pretty clear
idea of what that film ought to look
like
the storyline would be set almost 20
years after that of kill bill 2
almost 2 decades after the bright and
her daughter bb finally found peace
bibi now an adult would be played by
none other than huma thurman's daughter
maya hawk who already started once upon
a time in hollywood with tarantino
thurman herself would then obviously
embody the bride again
and presumably be seen on screen
alongside l driver sofia fatale
and goku's twin sister shiaki as we all
know tarantino is going to make
one more movie which is why after all
these statements the question naturally
arises whether this could already be
teaser for kill bill 3. unfortunately
not it actually appears to be nothing
more than an innocent gimmick
after all tarantino has already revealed
that his last film will be more of a
small epilogue and not a full feature
film
thus patience is still required
after it was announced almost a month
ago that the new tomb raider movie will
get a new script as well as the new
title obsidian there are now new details
about alicia become the second
appearance as lara croft as reported by
the side geek vibes nation things
suggest central america as the setting
similar to the video game shadow of the
tomb raider from 2018.
initially supernatural events were also
planned for the film but that was still
when ben wheatley was intended to be
director
on the other hand the series is now
directed by misha green and
she obviously has some expertise in
horror thanks to her serious lovecraft
country
the setting will be primarily based on
the mauin area as evidenced not only by
first logline for the story but
also by various casting calls a precise
release date
for tomb raider obsidian has not been
set yet but we will keep you up to date
as
always
[Music]